The Nobel Prize committee gives awards to
those who provide - “the Greatest Benefit
to Mankind” and a handful of dedicated scientists
make the cut every year.
This year’s winners tinkered with evolution
in the lab, developed therapeutics that fight
cancer and created lasers so powerful that
they can peek inside an atom.
They’re investigating science at the micron
level, and their groundbreaking discoveries
are completely changing the way we look at
our own world.
There are three major science categories for
the Nobel Prizes*; medicine, chemistry, and
physics.
And the Nobel Prize in medicine was awarded
for breakthroughs in immunotherapy.
James Allison and Tasuku Honjo developed research
that led to the rise of new immunotherapy
drugs.
See, our immune system has specialized cells,
called t-cells, that attack any foreign invaders,
like viruses or bacteria.
Think of them like your system's bodyguard,
they're looking out for any enemies in your
midst.
But that’s the thing with cancer, your own
cells are the enemy,so the t-cells don’t
know to fight them off.
So Allison and Honjo found a way to tweak
the t-cells by blocking two specific receptors;
CTLA-4 and PD-1.
This helped activate the immune system to
go after cancer cells.
Human trials started in the 2010’s and they’ve
been effective against a whole host of cancers.
Next up, Chemistry.
Frances Arnold, George Smith, and Sir Gregory
Winter split the Nobel Prize for their respective
work on directing evolution of enzymes and
antibodies.
You see, enzymes are the workhorse of the
cell.
They’re biomolecules with distinct jobs
that help us live, like synthesizing our nutrients
into energy.
Arnold’s research used enzymes’ natural
ability to adapt and mutate, and she mutated
them to the point where they would perform
even better than nature intended.
This was used by other scientists for years
and goes beyond medicinal practices.
For instance, she converted sugars to alcohol
for biofuels, which could help pave the path
for fewer fuel emissions.
Smith discovered something called phage display,
a method of hacking bacteriophages, which
are viruses that infect bacteria, to create
new proteins.
And then Winter used this technique to direct
the evolution of antibodies, leading to new
therapies to treat diseases like rheumatoid
arthritis.
And finally Physics, let’s roll in the lasers.
This prize was split among Arthur Ashkin who
developed “optical tweezers” and Gérard
Mourou and Donna Strickland who won “for
their method of generating high-intensity,
ultra-short optical pulses.”
Ashkin’s “optical tweezers” started
off with the idea that focused laser beams
have concentrated photons in the center and,
by placing two beams near each other, they
can create a “radiative” pressure on small
objects.
This causes objects to be trapped between
two lasers like a tractor beam out of movie.
This is useful for scientists who want to
trap tiny things, like cells and atoms.
Now Strickland and Morou creating controllable,
ultra-sharp laser beams.
Back in the 1980’s, instruments weren’t
equipped to handle super powerful lasers yet,
but Strickland and Morou found that if they
stretched out the laser pulses, it would reduce
its peak power enough.
The laser then could be compressed into the
ultrashort high-intensity pulses they wanted,
allowing us to look inside individual atoms!
This laser tool is used for semiconductors,
medical stents, and in corrective eye surgeries.
So there are immeasurable applications to
what these nobel winners have created.
Each one of them has made a technique or tool
that’s revised our view of the microscopic
world that we’re only still learning about.
They’ve laid important foundations in science
that are only extending our frontiers of knowledge
about the bigger world around us.
Like science in your day?
Go ahead and subscribe.
And if groundbreaking science to benefit mankind
is too vague of a standard for you, check
out this detailed video on what else you need
to win a Nobel Prize.
Although Nobel Prizes have been awarded for
to 923 people, only 48 of them have been women
and Donna Strickland marks the 3rd woman ever
to win a Nobel Prize in Physics.
You go Donna.
Thanks for watching!